all right so we'll we're going to jump
right into the first question
and the first question is
why did god allow sin to enter into a
perfect world
why do you think adam sinned
adam sinned because he chose to sin
it was not an accident the bible is
clear eve was deceived adam was not
first timothy chapter 2
excuse me 13 and 14. now sin was allowed
because the angels had to understand how
god functions go to first peter chapter
one let's read verses 11 and 12. first
peter chapter 1 verses 11 and 12.
this will tell us that the old testament
prophets while they were writing
did not fully understand what they were
writing
but they had to be told they were
writing for another generation so we'll
go to first peter
chapter one we read verses 11 and 12.
read very very carefully
do you have that
first peter 1
11 and 12.
searching what or what manner of time
the spirit of christ which was in them
did signify
when it testified beforehand the
suffering of christ and the glory that
should fall now verse 12 unto whom it
was revealed that not unto themselves
but unto us they did minister the things
which are now reported unto you by them
that have preached the gospel unto you
finish that verse
with the holy ghost come down from
heaven come on which things the angels
desire to look into which is the gospel
the angels do not understand
everything now compared to us
their minds are like encyclopedias don't
misunderstand me but they don't
understand everything
and so when lucifer fell
and the lord threw him out they did not
understand whether or not he was justly
treated
as a matter of fact ella white writes in
bible commentary volume 5 page 1149
paragraph 10
it was only when they saw what lucif
what satan did to christ on the cross
that the last strings of sympathy was
satan were cut
imagine this for 4
000 years and more
there were angels in heaven who felt
lucifer had been unfairly treated
god had to allow sin that's the reason
why god allowed cain to live that the
universe may see what happens as sin
proceeds and progresses it's a painful
thing for god because he hates sin
hebrews 1 verse 9 thou hast love
righteousness and hated iniquity and the
things we hate we try to avoid god
cannot avoid sin
that's why when all the wicked are
finally destroyed
including satan but before he is
destroyed
every knee shall bow
and every tongue shall finally confess
that jesus christ is lord that has to
happen and for that to happen sin has to
be seen for what it really is so that
those of us who are saved having seen
what sin does
we will choose to live in a world where
sin will never return again
so god had to let it happen
and proceed yes and god always knows
best
that's why to please god you must
interact with him by faith
because he's god we're not and there's
so much it's like children and parents
children do not understand why the
father the mother said no
the parents understand the child doesn't
next question all right well let's jump
right into some controversy let me say
something before we get into the
controversy
the question also why did adam sin
adam put someone ahead of god
genesis 3 verse 17 and unto adam he said
because thou has heartened unto the
voice of thy wife
and has eaten of the tree of which i
commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat
of it cursed is the ground for thy sake
god said you listen to someone else
instead of me
i hit a harp on this but let me harp
when you observe sunday
you're listening to someone else instead
of god
and i'll leave it at that yes